[Music]
[Music]
ladies and gentlemen please welcome to
the stage
dave ramsey
[Music]
[Applause]
a good plan
violently executed
now
is better than a perfect
plan executed
later
general george patton
if you're going to go into battle
you need a plan
if you're going to win a football game
you need a
game plan
and that's what we're doing tonight with
you guys here in the room and
those 40 000 or so of you watching
around the world thank you for joining
us this is all about putting together a
game
plan
it turns out that after all these years
of running a business now with about a
thousand folks on our team which is a
thousand opportunities for somebody
pissed off at each other
after trying to put together strategies
for ramsay this and ramsay that and
trying to understand how all this
business stuff works and studying really
successful people in history and getting
to know some really successful people it
turns out that as i watch people go from
nothing to baby steps millionaires
none of them say
it was an accident
success was an accident
they never go up to the guy at the end
of the super bowl
and the confetti is going off and the
little reporter runs out and says so
what happened he said i have no idea i
just get off the bus
then this just happened
winning
at anything
is not
an accident
and in most cases it is a violently
executed plan that is somewhat imperfect
but by god you did it you stepped up you
punched it in the nose and you took your
life by the ears and said you're gonna
behave
a violently executed plan a plan
executed with passion and belief that
causes you to sacrifice to win
because nobody really wins without
sacrifice
i mean all those times you bought a
lottery ticket and didn't win and then
you got one that won that was all the
sacrifice
and that seems somewhat random and it is
somewhat random and it's pretty much
stupid
but even when you win at something like
that it's not as random as much of a
lightning strike as you feel like it is
winning is a series
of behaviors habits decisions
implementations the cumulative effect of
a life well lived
we had a couple on the air today on the
ramsey show that did their debt-free
scream
75 years old been married 50 years
you don't stay married 50 years out
without her killing you
unless you learn something
along the way you got progressively
better
you get pro that's somebody you want to
interview on how to be married in a
culture that can't stand to figure this
thing out
they can't seem to get married then they
can't seem to stay married
and that's a study best practices study
people that are winning
so with the right plan
your life can change
and you'd be amazed at how much it could
change in just 90 days
i mean you can really
violently execute the plan and within 90
days you're going to see a
big thing change
george campbell ramsey personality is
with us tonight he's going to be talking
to you folks about goals and how to put
them in place how to implement them and
call how to win christie's going to be
talking from her brand new number one
best-selling book we found out today was
a number one take back your time
and how to how to handle your time how
to own
that stuff
and then i'm gonna come up and we're
gonna do a few minutes on how to have a
game plan of course
on your money i don't know anything
about anything else
and uh live stream we want to hear from
you guys we want to know in the comments
section uh what you think the number one
thing
that you have to do with money is
if you want to win
what's the number one thing you do if
you want to win put it in the comments
section
in the live stream
so our first speaker tonight ramsey
personality george campbell is
absolutely incredible he is a the the
host of the entree leadership podcast
which if you're not listening to when
you're in business or leadership or have
any interest in it you should be it's
absolutely phenomenal listen to it on my
walk this morning it was really really
good and also a brand new ramsey network
podcast that is
doing exactly what we hoped it would do
it's really ticking off some people
the bad people that are ripping people
off they don't like george
and they don't like the fine print you
ever seen you heard somebody say read
the fine print make sure you read the
fine print well you should have
because that's when you get screwed
right and george has got about 10
episodes in the can with the fine print
it's a wonderful new podcast on the
ramsey network be sure you check it out
and he knows this money piece and he
knows this ramsey way of life inside and
out we're so proud to have him as a
ramsey personality please welcome him to
the stage
george campbell
[Music]
wow
all right how many of you have failed at
a goal in the last 18 months show of
hands
ma'am you didn't have your hand up
you've accomplished all of your goals
you know you should be up here not me
show us your ways this is very
impressive
let me guess pandemic
it's a pretty good excuse i'm not going
to lie uh same here same here i've
failed at a lot of goals
in the past let me take you back to
december 2013. it was a simpler time
wasn't it
harkening back to december 2013.
old george had a lot of goals
or
i guess it was technically younger
george but it was an older time
old younger george had a lot of
aspirational goals for the year 2014
right high expectations for myself i
thought this is my year new year new me
baby let's go
i even had a word for the year you all
know about these word for the year
things you get your little theme so in
2012 my word was live
in 2013 my year
my word was laugh and in 2014 my word
was
no it wasn't love it was persevere how
did you guys not live laugh persevere
that's how the saying goes anyways i had
35 goals in all kinds of areas of life
and i was super excited i had my iphone
note ready to go
game on let's do this thing one of my
goals was to read 52 books in a year
the previous year i read one so it was a
little aspirational all things
considered i also said i was going to
work out three times a week and let me
tell you what it takes to get this body
is working out zero times a week
so i had big goals i was ready to go
week one crush the book i was on track
and i went to the gym a few times that
week i was doing great week two
things slowed down a little bit i read
an audiobook yes you can do that
at one and a half speed crush that
and i went on a walk so we'll count that
that's a win but week three things
derailed it wasn't even february yet and
i was googling to see if spark notes
were still a thing
and my workout was taking out the trash
it was a heavy load in my defense but
still
i had failed
right i joined the 92 percent of people
who never achieved their new year's
goals
which is normal right average
university of scranton found that 92
percent of people
never achieve their new year's goals
it's why january 1st the gym is packed
you can't get in and by valentine's day
there's a stairmaster for miles right
you don't have to do a dateline
investigation to figure out what
happened here people had weak goals
they had unclear motivation they had a
vague plan and they didn't develop
habits to help them get there that was
me
and i'm sure we've all been there for
the longest time i just thought i'm just
not wired for goals right it's for a
certain type of person it's for the dave
ramsey's and the christy wrights who
just get up and just attack the day and
they wake up at 5 00 a.m and they have
their quiet time and they go and run
they help out of the nursing home on the
weekends and they have great deep
relationships their marriages are
incredible they read thousands of books
a year and that's just not in the cards
for me
what about goals for the rest of us
for the average everyday people who
can't just crush it and charge hell with
a water pistol right i needed something
more than that
but here's what i know about goals we
are all designed for personal growth
every human on this earth is designed to
grow but we're also prone to failure and
apathy and laziness and oreos and shame
and guilt and frustration and
distractions the list goes on
and what george of 2013 didn't know
was that he was a few crayons short of a
full box when it came to goal setting
right i didn't have the full picture
but in the last eight years here at
ramsey i have learned so much from dave
ramsey from christy wright from the
entree leadership team
from our principals and i actually
achieved a whole bunch of goals
especially in the area of money in those
eight years i paid off thirty six
thousand dollars of student loan debt i
paid off four thousand dollars of credit
card debt and became completely debt
free
i started saving for emergencies i
started investing for the future and i
thought okay i guess i can accomplish
goals
but you need a secret sauce and i'm
excited to share that with you tonight
me and my wife she works here by the way
we met here it's a beautiful love story
that's for another time
we had a bee hag that's a big hairy
audacious goal to pay off our house
and we didn't want to do it in 30 years
like the average american if they're
lucky we didn't want to do it in 15
years
in 2019 when we moved into that house we
said we're going to pay this thing off
in three years
that is a big hairy audacious goal and
it scared me a little bit and a good
goal should scare you a little bit
and i'm so excited to announce
that in six months
we will have a paid for house in our
early 30s
thank you guys thank you
we're not special we're not rich we're
not masterminds we just followed a
proven process and we got a handle on
what it takes to achieve a goal and
that's what i want to talk to you guys
today about when i want to do it through
the lens of debt payoff because america
is broke and one of my goals in life is
to help them get a little more unbroke
okay i just invented that word tonight
and here's what it takes there are three
keys to setting goals and seeing success
the first key is to know your why
know your why
why are you doing this
you need to create a vision for your
life
before you set any goals you've got to
have a vision
proverbs 29 18 says where there is no
vision the people perish
and now i don't know a lot of old-timey
language so i looked up
what the word perish means
to die or be destroyed especially in a
violent or untimely manner
dang bible
why so serious
the bible literally says if you don't
have a vision you're roadkill
splat
you've got to have a vision you've got
to have a huge why and a vision behind
your goal because that's going to give
you a real reason to do it that's going
to be the engine that fuels this thing
so ask yourself where are you going and
why are you going there and that why
that can open a whole can of worms
because a lot of times you'll realize
you've got real bad motivations
you're trying to keep up you're trying
to do it for the gram
you're trying to cover up insecurities
you're trying to perform and please
others that is a bad plan we need good
motivations we need big whys i heard
someone on our debt-free screams today i
want to change my family tree
i want to leave a different legacy
i want to retire early i want to give
outrageously i want to lead a healthy
life and be able to play with my
grandkids those are good motivations
and if you want a good motive and you
want a big enough why you need to attach
a so that to your goals
i didn't make this up
one of the taglines for this place is
live like no one else so that later you
can live and give like no one else
you all memorized it and you may not
know that so that is really important
that is the vision that is the why you
got to have a bigger picture for your
life the picture of the person you want
to become your future self
and if you want to take this a step
deeper there's this new thing out there
that's really cool and it's called
identity-based goals and james clear
talks about this in his book atomic
habits
and here's what it says don't focus on
performance don't focus on
accomplishments and achievements focus
on the person that you want to become
the person you're becoming
identity-based goals tap into a deep
motivation that will transform you
transformation is way deeper than just
achieving a goal
james clear says you need to decide who
you want to be and then take small steps
to get there
you know small steps that kind of sounds
familiar doesn't it kind of reminds me
of baby steps
i think dave ramsey's onto something
this thing just might work
so as you're considering which goals to
set ask yourself
why you want to achieve this goal
decide what kind of person you want to
be and attach us so that to make it
powerful
and then you can start to become the
type of person who says no to debt who
pays cash for things who eats healthy
who works out regularly now
we've got to be realistic here i'm not
going to become dwayne the rock johnson
because i shave my head and get a spray
tan and start working out a lot right
i can't become six too the doctor says
there's still hope i'm 92 percent there
just math-wise
one of my favorite bands the aver
brothers they have a lyric that says
this decide what to be and go be it
and a lot of times we overcomplicate
goals we have excuses but that's really
what it comes down to
once we have that powerful why then we
can move on to step two which is make a
plan dave ramsey says goals are visions
and dreams with work clothes on and now
it's time to get to work
you need to have goals in these areas we
call it the wheel of life coined by the
great zig ziglar you've got to have
goals that are in the physical realm
intellectual career social financial
family and spiritual
picture this wheel as the wheel of a
bicycle and there's spokes within each
wheel and if one of those spokes becomes
weak or becomes damaged you get what's
called a flat tire
and that's dangerous that's inefficient
because when your life gets unbalanced
it's really unhealthy
right if you never skip leg day but you
skip all of your kids soccer practices
you become a really strong dude and a
really weak dad
and let me tell you i don't have kids
yet but i skip leg day all the time
and i get it parents i know what you go
through because i am a dog dad
okay so i'm on the right track with his
dad's stuff
so if you want to have goals that work
they have to be five things
a good goal must be specific
must be measurable must have a time
limit
must be yours
and must be in writing so let's unpack
these these are non-negotiables for a
good goal
so one and two specific and measurable
you want to lose weight wonderful you
want to pay off debt great that's not a
gold
how much give me a number 36 000 great
now we're cooking with gas we've got
that
now we got to figure out when
you want to lose weight you want to pay
off debt great when do you want to do
that two years all right now we have a
time limit
and now here's what happens we
sixth grade math starts to kick in and
you don't need to know the pythagorean
theorem it's just basic
basic division we've got to reverse
engineer this goal we've got to do some
backwards planning to figure out what
this is going to take
i want to pay off 36 000 of debt in two
years great now we can do some math
that's 18 000 a year that's 1500 a month
that's 346 dollars a week
now some of you are saying george that's
great math is wonderful but i don't have
an extra fifteen hundred dollars a month
to pay off debt
settle down dave ramsey's going to be up
here momentarily and he's going to show
you the game plan to actually get there
and how to create that margin in your
life through budgeting and all kinds of
things so divide out what it takes to
get to where you want to go
me and my wife did this before we ever
owned a home we were still in our
apartment we would jump on the ramsey
mortgage payoff calculator and we'd
start to dream up hey what is this going
to take
mathematics wise to pay off our house
early oh it's going to take thousands of
extra dollars a month towards our
mortgage which means we've got to create
a lot of margin
so you've got to figure out what it
takes to get there
number four the goal must be yours
not your mom's not your wife's
especially not your mother-in-law's
listen
you married her baby you are never going
to be good enough for her okay
don't do this do a goal because it's
yours because it's birthed out of your
visions and your dreams you've got to
own this thing
number five the goal must be in writing
goals aren't goals until they're written
down
right you got to type it out write it
out maybe you hang it up
underneath your rear view mirror in your
car maybe you put it on your bathroom
mirror maybe you hang it beneath your
live laugh persevere sign in your
kitchen
do whatever you got to do but you've got
to be able to see this goal regularly to
remind yourself and remind yourself of
the why
dr gail matthews is a psychology
professor at dominican university in
california and she did a study on this
and found that you're 42 percent more
likely to achieve your goal just by
writing it down
so there you go there's your life hack
for the day write down your goal and you
are halfway closer to getting there
here's a shameless plug for christy
wright's 2022 goal planner
which you can get right now if you want
to really go deeper into this and also a
shameless plug for my product that was
not released george campbell's dream
journal
that one died on the cutting room floor
dave ramsey did a hard note on that
i thought i had potential just saying
now you might be thinking all right
seven areas i gotta have goals in each
how the heck do you do this how do i
still have a life how do i balance this
all how do i prioritize well christy
wright's going to be up here in a little
bit to walk you through how to do just
that so i'm real excited for that we've
got to get clear on this plan they've
got to have those five things we've got
to have goals in all of these areas so
we don't get a flat tire otherwise it's
still a wish
and the third piece we need the third
part that i often didn't do which is why
i never achieved my goals was change
your habits
you've got to change your habits we
don't need more information i can google
everything in the palm of my hand i know
how to get skinny
i just don't want to do it
i mean i'm personally skinny but for all
of you out there who want to do that
i can give you the magic formula to that
and getting skinny is one thing but how
do you stay skinny right that's a
lifestyle change that takes a lot of
hard actions and hard pivots it means
eating things like kale chips
why would they put the word chips after
kale
that should be illegal
and don't get me started on cauliflower
steak
who decided cauliflower can be so many
things you can't just cut it up and
grill it and call it a steak where's the
beef
i want to know where the beef is this is
unbelievable this is a lie from the pit
of hell anyways back to habits
james clear defines habits like this
habits are small decisions you make
actions you perform every day
and researchers at duke university found
that habits account for 40
of our behaviors
which means your life today is
essentially the sum of your habits
good or bad some of you have great ones
some of you need to break some some of
you need to create some
we've got to create these smaller
consistent habits to help us achieve our
goals right that's why we have the baby
steps there's small incremental steps
you can take
so if you want to create a habit of
saving you might need to change a habit
of spending
if you want to lose weight you might
need to break up with ben and jerry
right
i know it's double heart you've got ben
and jerry it's a double breakup don't
worry they'll be okay they'll find
another lover
and you will find love again i believe
you this man is shaking his head no i
will not find love again
ben and jerry are my soul mates i
respect that
what i found is that you know we teach a
lot about investing around here and we
talk about compound interest when your
money makes money over time it's a long
game and habits are the same way habits
compound i found right if you go out to
eat one time you're not gonna go broke
you go out to eat every single day you
will get broke in a month
and if you eat one slice of pizza you'll
be okay you're not gonna get fat but eat
pizza every day for a month
and you will
it's amazing how that works compound
habits
one of the biggest reasons i failed at
my goals personally is that i was so
focused on the finish line i was so
focused on the outcome and i got tripped
up
you see goals are what you get this is
the outcome
but i think we need to flip this whole
thing on its head i think we're doing it
backwards what we need to focus on first
is our vision
our identity and our why what we believe
and then we can move into the processes
the systems that are going to get us
there what we do this is the habits and
guess what happens when you've got those
two and you actually form those habits
you get outcomes and you achieve your
goals
once i realized that it changed
everything for me i was so focused on
the goal itself and i was ignoring the
why i was ignoring the vision the
identity i was ignoring the processes
and systems it would take to get there
fm alexander says it this way people do
not decide their futures
they decide their habits and their
habits decide their futures
that'll preach
goals involve behavior change that's
what i found people don't talk about
that it just sounds fun to do goals what
they're saying is
change
that's what it is that's really hard
because it's way easier to go through
the chick-fil-a drive-thru than it is to
go home grocery shop and meal prep
right
it is their pleasure to serve me at the
chick-fil-a drive-through meal prepping
is no one's pleasure
no one gets pleasure out of that right
and psychologists don kelly and daryl
connor they come came up with this
emotional cycle of change that is
fascinating
and i'm gonna run it through this idea
of debt payoff there's five stages to
this it starts with uninformed optimism
this is where you watch a debt-free
scream and you go oh babe we could
we could do that we could we could be
debt-free we're going to go to nashville
and scream on the debt-free stage it's
going to be awesome
this is the most exciting stage you've
imagined all of the benefits and
experienced none of the costs
you've got a year's supply of rice and
beans you've got gazelle intensity your
alarm clock is just dave ramsey yelling
at you you are fired up you are ready to
go
but that phase is short-lived
unfortunately and you move into informed
pessimism
this is where you learn the reality of
what it takes to change you start to
question if it's worth it
oh gosh we gotta
cut the sports channels we gotta cut
cable we gotta stop eating out
we gotta start doing this budgeting
thing
i can't i have to skip brunch with the
boys are you kidding me this is hard
this is the part where you realize that
it takes some sacrifice to change
and then as you continue down you enter
the valley of despair
this is a dark place to be this is where
you start to cuss
and if you've got a spouse that cuss
word might be dave
right it's a four-letter word it works
and it's less salty than some other
words
but this is where you start to go like i
don't know if it's worth it
i'm going to give up i'm going to quit
this is when most people quit their
goals it's too hard to get out of the
slump they go back to square one they
get deflated you feel shame you feel
guilt you go of course you failed you
always fail you'll never achieve your
goals this is just like you isn't it and
you go yeah it is i'm going to go eat
some oreos and wallow right
this is most of america this is how we
treat goals
but if you power through this
and you realize i'm going to get back up
failure is
i can do this thing i can budget you get
to informed optimism
this is where you see some light at the
end of the tunnel and you realize it's
not an oncoming train
this thing just might work out you start
to get a little more excited you start
to see the power of the debt snowball
and you start to actually budge and go
oh my gosh we can create margin we have
money left over
and once you do that you get to success
this is the part we all dream about this
is the debt free scream on the stage
right above me
you realize the cost of change is worth
it and the actions that were once
uncomfortable
are now routine
so here's what i want to tell you about
the cycle of change
know that it's coming there are no
shortcuts you don't just get the frog
leap from uninformed optimism over to
success i wish it was that easy
but when you know that this is how your
brain's gonna work
then you can embrace the ride no that
you're gonna lose motivation that's why
you shouldn't rely on it you should rely
on discipline go listen to some jocko
podcast he'll scare you a lot more than
i do
this is where you go there's going to be
distractions there's going to be
roadblocks i'm going to have excuses but
be aware of it get above it and power
through and here's how you power through
i'm not saying just pull yourself up by
the bootstraps i'm saying use your big
why to power through
use those habits and the discipline that
you've created on the front end use
accountability use a plan like ramsay
plus and financial peace university and
total money makeover and podcasts and
books and all of these great resources
that can help you stay motivated and
power through
and expect to fail
you're not going to be great at
budgeting the first week or the second
week or the third week it might take you
90 days to get this thing dialed in
but i'm telling you it is so worth it
you've got to fall in love with patience
you're not going to do this stuff
overnight most people pay off their debt
in 18 to 24 months
it's not a long time but for most people
who have never achieved their goals this
feels like forever when you're paying
off debt and you're working the side job
and you're sacrificing but trust the
process
it worked for me it worked for millions
of people out there and it will work for
you too if you actually do this stuff
you know me and dave ramsey we hosted
the ramsey show today and there were
some inspirational debt-free screams on
the stage and i love celebrating our
fans i can't help but smile i want to
run through a wall after i listen to
these stories
and here's the thread i found even with
the ones today
it started with their identity
they decided
they're going to be different kind of
people
they decided that they're going to have
a big why that they want to change their
family tree that they're going to leave
a different legacy than the one they
grew up in
that they don't want to see their kids
saddled with debt in the same cycles of
shame and guilt so remember you are
designed for growth to get from point a
to point b
and that involves transformation
so let me recap here you've got to know
who you want to be
not just what you want to accomplish
you've got to have a plan for making
your goals happen and make it a smart
goal have those five things and have
them in those different areas and then
you've got to create habits to get there
and change your habits and change your
actions
you know one of the most inspirational
things i found and i didn't realize this
until lately but dave ramsey has signed
probably i don't know a billion
signatures in his lifetime that's a
conservative estimate
and underneath every signature if you
look closely
it says
transform underneath that it says romans
12 12. here's what that verse says
do not conform to the pattern of this
world but be transformed by the renewing
of your mind
that's
powerful
what that tells me is it starts with
belief
it starts with this belief that
things can be different for me that i
can transform that where i am today
doesn't have to be where i end up and
what that creates is a little bit of
hope
transformation starts when you decide to
change and it starts in the mind and
here's what i believe more than anything
for you all tonight
if you can change your mind
you can change your habits
and if you can change your habits
you can change your life
i'll leave you with this dave ramsey
quote
it's worth the trouble to become the
person that god made you to be
so my challenge to you is this
decide what to be
and go be it god bless you guys
thank you
so i gave you a lot of information right
now some of you didn't even know
cauliflower steak existed
uh but if you're feeling overwhelmed and
you're going towards this is all great
stuff man but i feel like it's going to
be another year where i'm overwhelmed
and i've got too many goals and you're
saying all these areas i need to have
goals in and i just don't know i don't
even know where to start
well my friend christy wright is about
to come up here and she's about to show
you how to actually fit this in to your
life that's already busy already crazy
already overwhelming she's going to show
you how to prioritize all of these
things and show you how to do the right
things at the right time and i don't
know if you heard but we are celebrating
her tonight because her book is a number
one bestseller across the nation we are
so pumped for that and it's for good
reason
this is life-changing content in this
book and you're going to get a taste of
that tonight she's a number one
best-selling author of course she's an
amazing mom wife teammate i'm honored to
get to work alongside her she's the host
of the christie wright show and she's
going to absolutely inspire you tonight
so please give me a warm welcome for my
friend christy wright
[Music]
wow i'm so excited to be with y'all
thanks for being here thanks for giving
up your night to hang out with us and
learn and grow in these different areas
of your life i'm so excited because this
session that i get to have with you is
something i'm not only passionate about
because i've been living it
reading researching writing on this
topic for a decade but it's something
that affects everything we're talking
about if you're going to reach your
goals you're going to need time to do it
if you're going to reach your financial
goals you're going to need time to do it
if you're going to activate this game
plan you're going to need time to do it
right so we're going to talk about how
to make that work now i'm going to start
by telling you um for those of you that
don't know me
my husband and i are complete opposite
personality styles i married someone my
complete opposite anybody in here marry
someone their complete opposite
personality style
yeah it's a thing the whole opposite's
attract it's a thing it works
ish right
most of the time i guess
so my husband is patient and steady and
introverted and quiet and loyal and
unemotional and prepared and practical
i am none of those things okay
but here's what we do have in common
we're both
pretty sarcastic we love to give each
other a hard time we love to kind of
like mess with each other and so
years ago
back when we were dating this was maybe
i guess 12 years ago back when we were
dating back before you know the most
exciting thing going on on saturday was
a trip to home depot okay before kids
back when we were in this running group
we would go on these adventures so we
would train for marathons do trivia
nights camping trips that type of thing
well there was this one particular day
where all these people it's probably
like 20 of us in this running group
and decided to go canoeing and i was
super excited i actually lived on the
harpith river and so i had my own yellow
canoe and so i was super excited and um
and like i said matt was always giving
me a hard time when we were dating and
flirting and stuff and he'd always give
me a hard time about missing out on
details like i would miss out the
details of what some race we were
supposed to do or i'd be late to
something because i just i'm just i'm
what dave calls a free spirit okay don't
box me in
so he was always giving me a hard time
about this well on this particular
saturday we're all meeting at target to
go
canoeing all of our friends there's 20
of us and so i loaded up the yellow
canoe on the top of my old
1996 jeep grand cherokee that smelled
like a go-kart and i prayed it back to
life more times than i can count and i
get to target first and i'm super proud
of myself i'm like i don't know it feels
like an opportunity to brag a little
so i pull up my phone and i start to
text matt again we're dating from that
little flirty you know whatever stage
and so i just draft a text to him and i
say well um
looks like i beat you to target
boom
hit send so i weigh like
i'm so clever
wait i see the little dots you know he's
typing back he's like
you're at the wrong target we're all
waiting on you
a couple seconds later boom
i was really proud of myself for getting
to somewhere i didn't even need to be
and you know what
we all do the same thing
we all rush really hard
to do things that don't matter
we work really hard to check off a to-do
list and never ask ourselves if any of
those things represent anything worth
doing
we show up to commitments on our
calendar and never question if those are
commitments we even care about
if they even move us in the direction of
the vision of our life
we work really really hard
for a life
that we don't even like
and we never question
if there is another way
we race so hard to get to a finish line
we don't even want to cross some of you
are amazing at answering emails and
checking off boxes on your to-do list
and showing up for meetings and
commitments on your calendars and we
never stop to ask ourselves if any of
those things represent anything
worth doing
peter drucker said there's nothing
quite so useless
as doing with great efficiency
that which shouldn't be done at all
and a lot of us
are so busy
not because
our world is crazy that's a piece of it
not because oh my gosh we just we're
just so important we're so busy we just
are such big helpers we're such a good
christian we love to save the day we're
we're so needed it's because we are
reacting doing things that don't even
matter
and we're used to it
we're so used to rushing around
we don't even know how to rest
we don't know how to stare at the
elevator doors and not pick out our
phone
we don't know how to be still
we don't know how
to even consider that when an invitation
comes through on our calendar
to even question if we want to do it if
it's right for us
if it matters
and then we sometimes are the worst we
pile on the pressure
you might knock out some of your to-do
lists and what do you do you just put
more on
you just pile more on
never even question you just pile more
on sometimes some of you guys are so
excited about your to-do list you go
back and put something on it when you've
already done it
just so you can check it off have you
done that say yes
yes
but you know what happens
we become
a cruel task master in our own lives
and we're tired
we're really really tired
we think the problem is we don't have
enough time oh i just need more time you
don't need more time
i gotta tell you you don't need more
time if you had more time you would cram
more crap in
you don't need more time the problem
is not more time and then we think oh
well maybe the problem with balance
maybe my problem with balance is i'm
just i just am not productive enough i
just need to do more i need to get more
productive
i need to get more efficient i know what
i need to do i need to become a morning
person
yes i need to become a morning person i
need to wake up earlier i need to pour
more coffee i need a better morning
routine i need a special app that's
going to help me help me multitask and
be efficient and productive and i just
need to run harder and run faster i need
to work smarter and harder no harder no
smarter i'm gonna multitask the smarter
and the harder and run really fast and
stay up later
and all we end up is
exhausted not more balanced
turns out the path to balance is not
productivity
the path's balance
is not doing more
you've tried that and it has not worked
it's not doing more
it's not being more productive
and what's so interesting with this word
balance and we've got a lot of feelings
about it
but what's so interesting
is that we can't even define it
we don't even know what we mean
but you can't achieve something you
never define
we don't know what balance is we're just
sure we don't have it
right
it becomes this shadow that haunts us
this thing that evades us we always feel
like we're failing oh i just need more
balance i need to balance it all how do
you balance all how do you balance
everything
it just becomes this thing that haunts
us and even if you hate the word and
lots of people hate the word dave ramsey
hates the word
this is something that even if you hate
the word
we can't stop talking about it
i have been a business coach for over a
decade
and the number one question that i have
been asked in the last 10 years is not a
business question
it's this question
how do you balance it all
how do you balance everything
how do you have work-life balance how do
you balance having a full-time job and
having side hustles where you're trying
to get out of debt how do you balance
having a work a full-time career and
having a family how do you balance all
the different goals how do you balance
it all
and we've got all the analogies don't we
oh we've got all the visuals we've got
juggling balls spinning plates walking a
tightrope and some balls are rubber and
some balls are glass which balls can you
let drop on a tuesday we've got all the
analogies can we just zack morris time
out for a second
like
can we talk about these images have you
ever seen a juggler
like that looks crazy y'all do you want
to live like that
like their whole body is wiggling around
trying to keep things flying there have
you ever seen a tight rope walker every
muscle on their body is tense
i don't want to live like that
every image you hear in regards to
balance from spinning plates to juggling
balls to walking tightrope sounds like
something in a circus
maybe this is the problem
our lives are a circus
and we wonder
what the problem is
and no matter what we do we feel like
we're doing the wrong thing
we just feel like we need to juggle
better and spin plates faster and walk
the tightrope i don't know about you but
that's not how i want to live my life
so it led me down this path as i started
writing this book it led me down this
path to ask a different question what if
balance isn't so much something you do
how you balance it all perfectly these
images that we have
what if instead balance is something you
could create
in your life
where you could actually have a sense of
balance
but still be busy
where you could be a balanced person
in an out of balance world
where balance
looks more like
peace
being confident in your choices when you
say yes to that thing or no to that
thing
being proud of how you spend your time
for once in your life
actually
enjoying your life
i think
that's what we're after
i think that's what we really want when
we say
we want balance
we don't want this perfect 50 50 split
what we want is to be proud of how we
spend our time in our one life we've
been given i think we want peace and
confidence and actually enjoying our
life this is not so much about the
calendar it's about enjoying the life
that that calendar represents
and it turns out the path to that
is not productivity
it's not just doing more
and so while we have all these mixed
feelings about the word balance oh you
know balance is juggling and spinning
plates and and walking the tightrope we
have all these analogies we also have a
lot of different definitions some people
think oh well life balance is a 50 50
split you work 50 of time you're at home
50 of the time this is what leads to
balance and it doesn't
you can do that
and still feel like something's not
right and by the way that's completely
impractical for most of us
but there's another definition and a lot
of people feel like well
balance is where you just do everything
all the time everything equally so every
day i'm gonna have my quiet time and my
quality time with my husband my quality
time with my kids my quality time alone
and my quality time with god and i'm
gonna work i'm gonna crush my goals hit
my to-do list be a good friend show up
at church and then oh by the way get a
workout in before bed
that's not realistic
and so i wanted to take this opportunity
to reclaim this word
to redefine this word to show you a
version of balance that is not only
possible but maybe just the type of
balance you're actually looking for
where you can take back your time and
actually enjoy your life and this
definition is this
life balance is not
doing everything for an equal amount of
time
it's about doing the right things at the
right time
when you do the right things at the
right time you actually feel that sense
of balance that you've been looking for
all along
but it wasn't because you did everything
it was because you finally gave yourself
permission to focus on the right things
that definition is the thesis of my new
book take back your time that george was
talking about but i want to boil this
book down to one question
okay i lay out a path in the book it's
five practical steps to balance but i
want to boil it down to one question
that you could take home today you can
literally go home talk to your spouse
talk to your kids and you can start
using this to determine your calendar
today here's the question
what's right
right
now what's right
right now here's the great news you get
to decide what's right for you in any
new season and guess what what's right
for you today might be different than
what was right six months ago six years
ago will be a year from now in any new
season your season will determine what
matters to you so you have permission
to focus on what's right
right now
think about this summer we had the
olympics this summer
olympians were training
how many hours a week for those events i
mean
60 70 80 hours a week that was actually
right for them
that was their version of balance
because they were doing the right things
at the right time it was the summer
olympics this is what they were training
for
a new mom that's just had a baby and
she's just trying to get
two hours of sleep at a time
she's trying to get one shower a week
and not snap at everybody because she's
got no sleep that's balance because you
know what she's doing the right things
at the right time
i had a farm in my early 20s with
feigning goats and a mini donkey which
is kind of weird but you know what it
was right
you get to decide what's right for you
i'm not going to tell you what you
should spend your time on
but what i do want to do is what i
believe good coaches do i want to ask
you questions that help you decide that
for yourself
what's right
right now
what's right for you
is it working three jobs to pay off your
debt snowball faster
maybe it looks like getting help to get
you out of the rut that you've been in
maybe what's right for you is changing
some of those habits that george
campbell talked about so that you can
actually get different results
what's right
right now here's what's so powerful
about this question and i don't want you
to miss it when you ask yourself what's
right right now you not only give
yourself permission to do that
to focus on that to make progress on
that to be present for it to be proud of
it which by the way that in itself is
pretty incredible in the world we live
in where everyone's weighed down by
guilt
but here's the awesome thing not only
are you focusing on what's right right
now and being present for it and proud
of it you shake the guilt
for all the things that are not right
right now
it gives you confidence to say no to
that invitation to decline that request
to not put those 19 things on your to-do
list because that's not right right now
and just because something's not right
right now
doesn't mean it will never be right
it just means it's not right
right now
so what's right right now for you
if you're going to do the right things
at the right time you need to know what
the right things are
what's most important
not what is good what is fun what are my
friends doing what are my neighbors
doing what do my in-laws think i should
be doing
no no
what is most important to you
right now
i know
i know
i know what you're thinking
but kristy
it's all important
i know i hear you it's all important
you've got all these things it's all
important i didn't think of that um when
i wrote this book i didn't
i didn't plan for that
it's all important no it's not
no it's not it's not all important i
hear it in your stories i hear it from
people i talk to even when they rattle
off their to-do list they say it as if
it's all created equal well you know i
mean i've got to pay my bills and steam
clean my couch cushions and i've got to
go to work and i've got to also make
homemade gluten-free muffins for
everyone in the neighborhood and also i
need to feed my kids and reorganize the
attic these are not created equal
everything is not important
and as long as you pretend like it is
as long as you refuse to acknowledge
that your time is finite news flash you
get 24 hours in a day if that's the
first time you've heard that i'm so glad
i could bless you today with this
information i'm here i'm here for you
you get 24 hours in a day
so you get to decide what makes the cut
just like in your budget
what makes the cut
and what does not make the cut what is a
priority and what is not a priority in
the season what is right right now and
what is not right right now
if you refuse
to acknowledge that your time is finite
and you just insist on cramming
everything above the line i can rush i
can multitask i can i can leave this one
a little early and and then speed
through traffic and then i can run here
and get there and i can and then i could
if that's your solution and you just
insist on cramming everything above the
line
then here's what i want you to
understand
you don't get to decide what drops
and you're steam cleaning your couch
cushions and your kids are starving
and you're reorganizing the attic and
you haven't paid your bills
and you're focusing on the wrong thing
because you never
took the time to be honest with yourself
about what's actually important to
prioritize those things to determine
what's right right now and choose
what's not going to make the cut
what does not
fall above the line
this simple concept of prioritizing as
tactical as it is i got to tell you guys
we suck at it
we're pretty terrible at priorities
we're pretty terrible at prioritizing in
a tactical way with our budget or
especially with our time we just think
we can multitask and run harder drink a
little more coffee we can get it all in
but here's the truth
we need to understand what i actually
mean by priorities because i do hear
some misunderstandings around this word
some people no one in this room i'm sure
but some people think of priorities as a
set it and forget it thing right like
you have one set of priorities for your
whole
life they're in concrete signed in blood
and they never ever ever change i hear
people say sometimes like well i know my
priorities my priorities are god others
self in that order
i'm like that is a beautiful sunday
school answer that didn't help me manage
my tuesday right
so here's what i want you all to
consider okay yes
we all have a set of what i call fixed
priorities fixed priorities would be
your list of priorities if push comes to
shove and all hell breaks loose this is
what matters in this order my children
of course fall above my work in that
order in this list
if god called me to do something yes i
would submit to god in a very practical
way in this order of fixed priorities
you probably have that
now thankfully
we don't live in a world where push
comes to shove and all hell is breaking
loose on a regular basis thank the lord
for that
so here's what you need
you also need a second set
of what i call flexible priorities
these priorities are more current
more relevant more specific
than your fixed priorities so they might
look something like this
in the spring for example in the spring
i sat down with my husband we talked
about the spring season one of our
parties was getting our boys to swim
it's pretty specific the summer was
coming up they were age appropriate we
love to be around the water
so you need priorities that reflect the
season that you're in that are more
specific so you know how to manage your
time
well because we decided that
then every friday i went by their school
picked them up put them on one piece in
february took them the ymca got in the
pool and practiced swimming this summer
put them in swim lessons
and now both of my boys are jumping off
the high dive and swimming across the
pool that didn't happen by accident
it happened because i determined that
that was a priority and that informed my
calendar in a practical way
some of you
never feel successful in your how you
manage your time because you just never
define what success is
you don't know what you want to do in
the season you never stop you never even
stop to consider yourself before you
pile on the pressure
what would it look like to start each
season
or each week or each day and go
what matters most to me today how am i
doing
where you check in with yourself and you
consider yourself before you pour the
coffee pile on the pressure and just run
and react
where you started a season and when i
say season you can define what that
looks like for me my my year kind of
falls in three main seasons
spring summer and fall with work with my
kids calendar that type of thing and so
i will literally start a season and cast
a vision say what do i want this season
to look like so let me give you an
example i love walking through examples
in the summer
it was a lighter season at work
it was lighter in general we have less
events in the summer fall and spring are
pretty busy so i was taking time off my
house was pretty clean i saw my friends
a lot had a lot of good quality time
with my kids i was working out like all
these things were making the cut because
it was a lighter season
okay this season's different okay we
have transitioned from that season
so now three things make the cut
work launching my book that comes first
my kids that comes second now before you
write me off and send me your hate mail
about how i'm a terrible mom
these are flexible priorities that are
more honest more current relevant and
specific to the season you're in so if i
get an opportunity to go to new york and
talk about this book because i want to
help a lot of people i'm going to say
yes to that it doesn't mean i'm a bad
mom it means i'm honest about what i'm
focusing on with my time
so first and foremost is launching a
book from work second my family i'm
gonna be with my kids and my husband
anytime that i'm not doing that and
third i'm in seminary
it's pretty consuming
all three of those are pretty consuming
now here's what i want you to understand
i'm not seeing my friends very much i'm
not working out very much and my house
is not near as clean as i'd like it to
be
but because i'm doing what's right right
now for me i'm focusing on what's right
right now for me i am able to walk
through my living room step over toys
and instead of beat myself up for what a
failure i am like i would in the past i
can look at those toys and go girl
that's not right right now
you're reading 300 pages a week on
revelation you're doing great
what's right right now for you
what makes the cut
when you determine what your priorities
actually are you can put them on your
calendar and spend time on them you can
focus on them be present for them be
proud of them and then so importantly
you can shake the guilt
for all the things that are not right
right now
i don't know what season you're in
i don't know what your financial goals
are
i don't know what your marriage goals
are i don't know what your fitness goals
are
i don't know
what your life looks like maybe you've
got a parent that you're taking care of
that has a health diagnosis and taking
care of them is a one
maybe you've got a child that's really
struggling and you've got to be hands on
with them and you've got to really take
a lot of extra time
ask yourself what's right
right now
when you do this you will finally be
spending your time on what's right for
you and you will be able to create your
version of balance
my mom um some of you have heard me talk
about this before
but my mom started a little cake shop
when i was six months old to raise and
support me
and while it's a cute story to tell my
childhood was less than idyllic it was
not pinterest perfect she pulled me out
of bed at two and three in the morning
to go to the cake shop so she would bake
cakes in downtown nashville i remember
i'd go to sleep on the 50-pound bags of
powdered sugar and flour and make a
little bed at three in the morning and
go to sleep there until it was time to
go to school
and uh i remember i would take over her
baking racks and she needed to like cool
the cakes and like i'm sorry my baby's
sleeping
but i remember the struggle
i remember going to the cake shop one
time
at um four in the morning
still pitch black outside and someone
had broken in there was glass everywhere
we didn't know if the person was still
inside i remember getting a flat tire in
the rain mom had an old car that was
always having problems mom was a single
mom and i was an only child and i was in
the struggle with her
but here's what i want you to know as i
look around this room and i know you
guys at home as well
of all these parents
you might
feel fear that you're harming your kids
by the struggle
by oh we've got some tough times we've
got to make some sacrifices we're paying
off debt dad's taking three jobs mom's
got a side business we're hustling we're
doing everything we can no i'm sorry we
can't go on vacation and christmas is
gonna be smarter smaller
here's what i want you to hear from me
as the child of a mom that struggled
i did not make it despite the struggle
i made it because of it
my mother did not teach me work ethic
and character and perseverance and
persistence she lived it out in front of
me and therefore i learned it i am who i
am because of my mother so don't you
dare be sorry for the struggle whatever
season you're in you have permission to
do what's right for you when you do
you're not just gonna be doing the right
things at the right time you're not just
gonna be creating balance you're going
to take back your time you're going to
take back your life
thank you guys so much for having me i
love being with you guys thank you
thank you thank you
and now
to bring us home
i have the pleasure of introducing the
man himself the main event the founder
of our company new york times
bestselling author and the man we all
know and love mr dave ramsey please
welcome to the stage
[Music]
wow
very cool
so proud of her
y'all remember
when we had a pandemic
so i had never been through one of those
before maybe you have
but um
it was hard
i got a thousand people on my team and a
lot of them are
youngsters and they have little babies
and some of them are single moms and
some of them are single dads and
i was
really
worried
that some of them were not going to have
a job
it scared the crap out of me
it was stressful
and i went i mean we we came here to
ramsey solutions
the team went home to quarantine you
know we had to do that stuff for a
little while and before they all came
back they're working from home and they
were actually working from home which
usually work from home doesn't mean that
but
it doesn't mean much work
but um
they were actually working and we were
trying to figure out how to like keep
ramsey open uh not because i need more
money i got plenty of money i'm okay
with that but i just feel this
tremendous responsibility as their
leader
to make sure that that single mom has
money feed her kid and that comes from
payroll that is created by revenue at
this company y'all know what i'm talking
about so it was i i
never been anything i mean i'm just a
kid from antioch tennessee and i grew
this thing and
now i've got this weight and i have to
figure this thing out
and it scared the crap out of me
we were down here we were working at
this office and we're doing media
appearances trying to give people hope
and we're
you know we're riding up and doing and
we're pivoting so much that we think we
just got one leg and you know and um
don't ever tell me to pivot again i'll
hit you and um
uh and unprecedented there's another
word i don't ever want to hear again you
all know what i'm talking about
is just shoot me and um
we were we were down here we're working
like 16 hours a day
and we i was just working like a madman
and not not again not because of greedy
needed money i don't need money i could
have just gone home and put my feet up
but i believe i was responsible for
those families that i told them i was
going to pay them and i should do that
and so we're working like crazy
and i found out something about myself
during that time
um
i you know a lot of you react
differently to stress than i do i i
first thing i do is i get pissed off and
and i'm just in a fight mode y'all know
what i mean you just get in fight mode
and it's like anybody who said anything
i just wanted to hit them it was just
awful i had to i had to really guard my
tongue and my spirit because i was just
in
mode right and so and the other thing i
found out is when i'm stressed out
i eat
a lot apparently
and so i gained like 37 pounds or 40
pounds
in just like no time because apparently
i ate every donut in a 50 mile radius
it was awful
and
i was you know i was working all the
time but then i walked past a mirror in
the daylight once before i got to you
know and i went wow
fat boy
this is not good
and uh i said we got to fix this this is
cray cray i mean i'm just going to
explode i look like i've been stung with
a bee you know it was just and so uh
wow
so i got like this app to count my
calendar calories and i got another app
that counts how many days in a row i
walked a mile and then how many days i
walked two miles and then how many days
i ran a mile and then how many once this
weight started coming off and uh i quit
eating every donut inside i hadn't had a
doughnut in 14 months i just swear to
god that's the truth and
i just quit i had to
and i lost 37 pounds
i mean but i got so fat
you know what i just said you know
enough
you know it's kind of like when i was
growing up you know again i kind of grew
up hillbilly kid and and my mama was a
sweet lady but she'd have enough after a
while you know what i'm saying and all
these kids running out of the house
running out of the house your mom ever
say stuff like uh you know were you
raised in a barn close the door the air
conditioning the whole neighborhood
close the door this is the kind of stuff
she'd say all day long and be kids in
and out of the house any other house and
finally she would turn with this look in
her eye with a butcher hand and butcher
knife in one hand and a wooden spoon in
the other
and she would say that's it
the worm has turned
and we had no idea what that meant
except the beatings were about to begin
you know what i'm saying
found out later the worm has turned with
shakespeare who knew mom knew
shakespeare but
that's it i've had it
when you say that
and you mean it
you're about to change your life
and until you say that
and you mean it
it's a freaking wussified intellectual
exercise
and you're not going to do it
it has to be visual visceral and come
from down inside of you
and you say
that's it fat boy get away from the
donuts
you got to say that's it i'm sick and
tired of making this much money and
having nothing to show for it i am sick
and tired of being sick and tired now
you're ready to change your life
and until you do that you won't
i was 28 years old
i borrowed way too much money in a real
estate nothing down scheme that i got
myself into i made a lot of money but i
built a house of cards and it fell in on
me and i lost everything i owned and i
went bankrupt and i had to start over
and i was a baby christian and i was
just learning what the bible said about
anything and i learned the bible had
some things to say about money and i
compared it with my grandpa's common
sense and it sounded similar
and i went that's it
i've had it
one of the benefits of going broke
is that you no longer care what other
people think
you're just like
i really would just like to eat now i'm
not really concerned about your opinion
or your broke brother-in-law's opinion
and by the way you live in washington dc
which pretty much makes you an idiot you
know
so
i'm just not gonna i don't need any of
this stuff i need i need to learn like
something that i can actually apply in
my life and feed my family and control
the controllables and control my destiny
i can't control everything but i can
control the old boy in this mirror and
if i get him under control he can get
some stuff moved around
and i started learning about money now
george talked to you about goals and he
said set very specific goals put a time
frame on them very good stuff christy
talked to you about how to take your
time back and get this stuff lined up
and what we're talking about here is
the whole idea that
personal finance
is 80 behavior
it's only 20 of head knowledge
the problem with my money is the guy i
shave with every morning
if i can get that guy to behave he can
be skinny and rich
but he has
issues and he has to say
i've had it
i'm ready to change
i got a bunch of youngsters working on
my team and they
they're wonderful
everybody gives a millennial generation
a hard time and i got to tell you i
disagree i think this millennial
generation is absolutely amazing
the the there's only two kinds
awesome and sucks
i mean they're either entitlement
driven arrogant little brats who think
because they have a social media account
that they actually should have an
opinion
or
they are the biggest hearted
hardest working smartest
driven charge the gates of hell with the
water pistol people you've ever seen in
your life they're the most crusaders of
any generation i've ever worked with and
i got a building full of them i love
them
i think they're amazing
and they're easy to interview because
they come in and they go i'm awesome or
i suck you know they'll tell you in the
interview right
you can just decide not that one and yes
on that one yeah and it's just a lot
easier so i got a good one but i'm
coming around the building and there's a
little guy doing the stuff he's supposed
to be doing wrong and i'm like don't do
it that way do it this way and he said
yes sir and i came back a week later and
he's doing the stuff he's supposed to be
doing wrong i said don't do it that way
and i came back a week later and he's
doing it wrong again i said boy we're
going to set you free in jesus name
i haven't told you three times there's a
right way to do this the wrong way to do
this and i happen to sign your check
it's not good management technique but
just gotta sometimes get through and so
he looks at me and he says but i'm not
like you
and i said i know i'm right you're wrong
we're different
you need to be more like me this is what
i'm trying to convince you of
he says yeah but and i said no
change
isn't it interesting that you can just
decide
to
change
you have that power
you being a jerk to your wife
change
you you grouchy every night when you get
home and you're snapping your kids
change
you don't work so much or you never show
up on time
change
isn't it fun
you can just decide
and that is a game plan by the way you
finally say i've had it
no donuts
i don't like my clothes not fitting
y'all get it
i don't like being broke
i've been collecting airline miles and i
have no money
i fell for a bunch of lies by banks
no more i changed just like that isn't
that fun
i just decided you know what i don't
have credit cards anymore
they haven't made me successful
so i'm gonna have a plastectomy
plastic surgery discover freedom
american distress
marriott why would i ever do that
target
almost got away
bank of america
citibank
chase what's in your wallet money
you're weird you don't have any credit
cards you're i don't have any credit
cards i went broke remember
this is my wallet
i have
throw four pieces of plastic in here and
some green president's faces
i i have a debit card on my business and
a debit card on my personal account and
my driver's license and my handgun carry
permit
and that's the only plastic i got
and for those of you from another world
or another country or something in
tennessee we actually have guns it's
weird and so
but uh
you all are all safe i promise but
but you know i mean is it weird
and and
i just decided so here's the thing
normal
sucks
it's mediocre it's average it's typical
it's bad you don't want a normal
marriage you don't want normal kids for
god's sake
you've seen them in the restaurant
you don't want a normal physique
have you seen that i had one you know
getting rid of it got not quite done but
yeah all right i mean you certainly
don't be normal with money 36 of
americans don't have the cash to cover a
400 emergency
400 bucks
and this isn't a country where the
average household income is 60 000 a
year
and they can't come up with 400 bucks
why you people spend it like you're in
congress
78 of americans live paycheck to
paycheck that's eight out of ten houses
on your street are broke they have too
much month left at the end of the money
number one caused a divorce in north
america today money fights and money
problems because in those 8 out of 10
houses life is not fun
we're just barely making it
because we bought a bunch of crap
with money we didn't have to impress
people that we don't even really like
and it's sitting in the driveway
and it's sitting in the bedroom and
sitting on the wall
and i had to have a new one a better one
a bigger one
and the richest country the world has
ever known
normal is broke
55 percent of workers say they are not
where they need to be with their
retirement goals earl nightingale used
to say people spend more time
picking out a suit of clothes than they
do picking their retirement plan options
so we're talking about game plans
tonight i want to give you three
elements of a really good game plan
now at the beginning of the night i told
you to write you guys in the stream to
put down on your comments what you
thought the most important money element
is and i'm going to give it to you right
now it's get on a budget
do a written plan
i told you at the beginning of the night
no one wins by
accident
a budget is a written plan a budget is
goal setting like george taught you for
money
jesus said don't build a tower without
first counting the cost unless you get
halfway up and you're unable to finish
it and all who see you begin to mock you
and say this man began to build and was
unable to finish
my friend john maxwell used to say or
does say
that a budget is people telling their
money what to do
instead of wondering where it went
you ever sit down and do your taxes
you go we just made a hundred and ten
thousand dollars would somebody tell me
where it went
i'm wondering where it went because i
never told it what to do
my friend zig ziglar used to say if you
aim at nothing you'll hit it every time
winning is not an accidental event
it is the cumulative effect of positive
habits and positive processes and
systems that you put in your life
whether it's to lose weight to have a
great marriage to be balanced in your
time to set goals or to
handle your money
on paper
on purpose before the month begins
if you worked for a company called you
incorporated and your job that you
incorporated was to manage money for you
incorporated and you look down and you
manage money the way you manage money
now would you fire you don't answer that
then don't pray and ask god to send you
money
because he loves you enough to say no
you suck at money
why would i give you more it will
destroy your life
you ever seen people get a lot of money
that are bad at it it messes them up
and god loves you too much he says only
when you're faithful with the little
things well then i give you more to
manage
my son when he was 16 14 years old he
said daddy i want to get a brand new
corvette when i turned 16. i said son i
have seen you drive you suck at this
you will not be getting a new corvette
it's 465 horsepower 0 to 60 in 2.8
seconds you in fiberglass body
you kill yourself and somebody else
what kind of idiot father would give a
child a rocket ship on wheels that can't
drive
you will be getting an old chevette with
a tired gerbil under the hood
and when you are faithful with the
little things my son
you will be given more to manage
trusted with a nicer car
but don't be going a hundred are
responsible i have no savings i'm deeply
in debt i don't do a budget but god
would you send me money
he won't answer that prayer the answer
is no
that's a possible answer to prayer some
of people don't know that but that's a
that's a biblical thing by the way
no
because your heavenly father is crazy
about you he's not going to hurt you
and money when it comes to people that
are messed up makes them more messed up
it's a pretty simple equation
so
change
we're going to do a written plan
on paper
on purpose before the month begins i'm
going to be proud of my eating habits
i'm going to be proud that for
542 days as of this morning i have
walked or run one and a half to five
miles every single morning but three
when i was in bed with some kind of
mysterious fever
isn't that interesting
i know exactly where i am it's a
measurable thing what you measure is
what's going to occur in your life i
know how many calories i've eaten i've
now logged
474 consecutive meals
i know exactly what's going into my body
consequently i'm not as fat as i was
why is this a miracle
you won't be as broke
when you make your money behave
on paper
on purpose
before
the month begins you'll feel like you
got a raise and for those of you that
are married
if you do it together the way you're
supposed to
it will create communication
that your spouse has always yearned for
you will talk about things that you
never talked about before
just kind of drove past them and i don't
even know when you do that without me
deal with that when you talk about money
right you got to deal with it
because you spend your money on what's
important to you
and when you align what's important to
you that's called unity
in your marriage
most marriage counselors use budgeting
as a technique to force couples to
communicate that are struggling
and even if you're not struggling you
will do much better shannon i don't
fight about money because we agree
on what is on the paper before the month
begins
every month on paper on purpose before
the month begins it's a habit now
it's fairly easy now because there's a
lot of money on it
used to be it was really tight
and there's little kids and we were
scared to death then we didn't know what
we were doing
nowadays all these years later there's a
lot more margin in there but it's still
on purpose we get a big old hairy check
from a publisher we still sit down and
go big hairy check coming what are we
going to do with it
on paper
on purpose before the month begins no
one wins accidentally or randomly you
plant corn and mysteriously corn grows
as you sow so shall ye reap
every time i plant stupid desperate
grows
and i have had some serious crops of
stupid come in
at times in my life y'all may have never
done this but i've got a phd in dumb
i've done it all wrong
i know how this feels
the second thing is get out of debt now
you knew dave ramsey was going to say
that
why because when you don't have any
payments you have money
your most powerful wealth building tool
is your income
the average car payment in america today
is 526
over 84 months let me help you with a
little math if you're 30 years old and
you invest 536 dollars in a decent
growth stock mutual fund in a roth ira
from age 30 to age 65 you'll have about
5.4 million dollars that's what your car
costs you i hope you like it
meanwhile the stupid thing's going down
in value like a rock that's where chevy
got that like a rock
and you ford people are no better at all
it's found on the road depreciated
f-o-r-d okay
they all go down in value we love our
cars
now some of you ladies think it's just a
very large purse but guys we love our
cars
but they're the largest thing we buy
that goes down in value and you walk
around the car payment going well
everybody has a car payment everybody's
life sucks
you won't be like everybody normal's bad
we established that earlier
78 percent of americans are living
paycheck to paycheck but new two new
cars sitting in the driveway in a bass
boat well i need a bigger engine because
those bass were out running me what
six hundred dollar boat payment shoot me
and get it over with
and wonder why your kid's college fund
didn't fund it
your largest wealth building tool is
your income
children do what feels good adults
devise a plan and follow it
we change
dave can you get me out of debt and we
have people come in you know the
borrower is slave to the lender you all
know that right
we have people come in the office all
the time they go you know sally mae's
got her own bedroom
we've got american distress and
we bought a new car and then we bought a
house we can't afford oh man this is not
gonna go well
people come in our office look like this
all the time they're like dave
can you get me out
yeah but it's gonna hurt
we're gonna have to amputate the tahoe
what
you mean i can't own things that i can't
pay for not if you want to be wealthy
because you're giving all your money
them
it's all going to them
when all the money comes in and all the
money goes out
and only the names are changed to
protect the innocent the borrower is
slave
to the lender it's a mathematical thing
it's a spiritual thing it's a relational
thing it's an emotional thing it's a
psychological thing it's stunting
america's growth
we have an epic student loan
problem
trillions of dollars
kids in their 20s are putting off
getting married having kids putting off
buying a house because they're
overwhelmed and slammed and destroyed
because idiots in washington and in
higher ed told them that no matter what
you pay for a degree it's worth it bull
crap
so i got 225 000 invested in my
left-handed puppetry degree
but it came from a big name famous
university which means i can now get a
job pouring coffee somewhere
and this is the lie that we told people
i'm not for being dumb i like education
i just don't like overpriced surprise
stupid education from famous
universities
that make you think you're somebody
because you went there
i went to a state school graduated in
four whole years i paid for it all but
it'll be student loan
but then it wasn't very expensive back
then i worked 60 hours a week shut up
dad gum whining
deal man you gotta decide
no more
i'm done
well dave i use my cards for the points
we uh you know we did the largest survey
of millionaires ever done in north
america we interviewed 10 167 of them no
one's ever done a research project this
size on millionaires
we finished it about three years ago
and you know a strange thing it's just i
know it's weird but
we interviewed we asked them how they
did it we asked them what they used how
did you become a millionaire by the way
90 89 of them did not inherit the money
that caused them to become a millionaire
just by the way just in case you were
wondering about the statistics so some
of you people are lying okay about that
yeah
and so these are actual this actual
research is called data facts okay and
so
and um
everyone inherited their money that's
wealthy you are a leftist socialist pig
okay that's just not true
now
got that out of the way i feel a whole
lot better now
all right but um
they didn't inherit their money it's a
fact
regardless of your politics or which
form of economics you're in okay but but
the truth is this
not a single one of them
said
dave you know i made all my money
with my airline miles
not a single millionaire said that
and yet i hear people all the time going
you know i'm i'm winning
i'm using the card
responsibly
i just haven't found that to be true
not in real data anyway
it's feelings and it's justification for
behaviors it's like yeah i know but i
can eat 16 donuts because i have a high
metabolism rate well i don't apparently
so
i don't have that as an option i had to
change
and i haven't had a credit card in 30
years
and i'm doing okay
isn't that
weird and see the whole idea of getting
out of debt is you first have to
actually believe you can
you have to actually look at the math
and go i mean y'all if any of you listen
to the ramsey show it's amazing to me i
have people call up they make and sixty
thousand dollars a year they have forty
two thousand dollars in that i'm gonna
do
can you get by on 120 for a year and
clear it
oh wow i never thought i could get out
of debt
they didn't even thought about the math
to me it's just like a ratio of shovel
to hole how big a shovel you got what's
your income versus the hole you're in
and look at that shoveled hole ratio and
i can divide into it pretty quick and go
you know you make 140 a year you got 80
000 in debt let's do 40 a year for two
years you're out that's you know i can i
mean you got 80 thousand dollars in debt
we can do 40 a year for two years you're
out shut up shut up do it
but you have to believe and sometimes
you have to sit and do the math to
actually believe
that you can do it henry ford used to
say if you think you can or you think
you can't you're right
you're
right are people like me
what are people like you i understand
where you come from where i came from
what's that mean
every place that anybody came from any
color any sex any background
any history any
ethnicity whatever you want to measure
were in the millionaire studies they
were all there
it was not it was not based on where
they came from it was based on where
they were going to
they got them there
they said uh-uh
i'm not living like i was raised
cray-cray back there not doing this
y'all know what i'm talking about
you know we're not doing this
and it's not a disrespect to the last
generation it's just going didn't work
well trying something new
change
was it harder for some people yeah some
are dumber than others
some don't work as hard as others it's
harder for me i mean look at this i get
to be on tv i'm not sure why i should be
just on radio with his face right and so
but
you know i mean i'm on everything but
it's just because they want to hear my
mouth i guess i don't know but i mean
peyton manning throw a football better
than me that's just not fair y'all
brad paisley
play guitar better than me just not fair
so it's easier for people that are
beautiful and talented and
but i didn't get dealt that hand so i
got to deal with this guy this guy is my
problem payton ain't my problem
i can be jealous and bitter and envious
and all these stupid emotions or i can
just go dave let's get with it son
i'm going to take responsibility
for what i got dealt and from here we're
going doesn't matter where you're coming
from all that matters is where you're
going to
that's all that matters
and i've got data to prove it to you
regardless of your background where the
little man can't get ahead what's he or
your spirit animal i mean come on
of course the little man can get ahead
it's about all that gets ahead these
days
washington has seen to it that the big
man gets his head cut off
they take everything from him and y'all
noticed
i mean
the rich people get all the breaks no
they don't
it's quite the opposite
we have 51 percent of americans have
paid zero federal income tax
the little man is getting a deal
so use it
and change
and go be somebody
a decision y'all
it's a decision
you can do it
the third one is when you're on a
written plan
and you get yourself out of debt see
when you don't have any payments it's
easy to build wealth
it's easy to save money it's easy to buy
things and pay cash for them
when you don't have any payments when
you go out of the payment business
you're just going to have money to do
stuff with
it's a weird thing so it's worth the
price
it's worth it to say i've had it
we're selling so much stuff the kids
think they're next
i've had it we're going to list our
debts smallest to largest and pay
minimum payments on everything but the
little one and we're going to attack the
little one with a
vengeance
a good plan violently executed today
is better than a perfect plan discussed
in your mother's basement on a blog
now i'm a financial blogger
isn't that neat
i'm not gainfully employed my mommy does
my clothing
but i'm a financial blogger
these are the influencers in our culture
today
god help me
so now
get up off your butt
go sell so much stuff work
my grandmother used to say is a great
place to go when you're broke to work
this is what's right right now six jobs
i'm tired of being broke
lots of ot i'm tired of being broke
i had three nurses this year come in
made
six hundred thousand five hundred
thousand and seven hundred thousand
dollars this year as traveling coveted
nurses
you know what they saw coved as an
opportunity to pay off their house
now they're brave souls and they put
themselves out there in the unknown
world it's a crazy world we live in
there to be admired for that but they
had a goal and they saw an opportunity
and there's never been a window ever in
the history of mankind that i know of
that a nurse traveling or otherwise
could make six or seven hundred thousand
dollars in one year but i had three of
them this year do their debt-free
screams on the show paid off everything
went from almost bankrupt to millionaire
in one year
work is a powerful thing
especially when you've got something
like that you can do
pretty stinking a good extra job you
know as far as the mathematics now i
don't have any idea about the medical
part and i bless their hearts for being
incredibly brave i don't i don't know
what i would have done because i'm
pretty much a wuss when it comes to
stuff like that
the third thing when you get yourself
out of debt
and you get on a plan
is be outrageously
generous
live with an open hand
even a dog understands this
come here baby
you do this the dog goes whoa
human beings
this is an open spirit
this is a spirit of abundance
this is a spirit of scarcity
live with an open hand
you can't take it with you anyway
i never saw a rider truck fall on a
hearse
so
you know live with an open hand
live like no one else pay a price to win
so that you can live and give
like no one else that don't be
irresponsible
be wise
and don't give drug dealers money to be
better drug dealers that's not what
we're talking about
not talking about being a child with
your generosity be wise be an adult with
your generosity
but you know what you can do with a
thousand dollars you can buy a single
mom a car it changes her life
you know what you can do with ten
thousand dollars you can do that ten
times
you know where you get ten thousand
dollars you don't have a car payment
anymore
and magically
about three years later you're gonna
start to have money
if you keep working
it's a most amazing thing
set you in a position to be unbelievably
generous
live with an open hand
it's really about all this is good for
is taking care of your family
and taking care of others
it's not good for much else i mean it's
okay to have some nice things i'm not
against that but if eating a lobster it
tastes like soap
only so much you can do with nice stuff
and it starts to run out you know what
i'm saying
he starts to be all sudden it's not nice
anymore it's not fun after a while
but generosity never gets old
your heart is
designed to be a giver because god's a
giver and you're made in his image
here's what i want you to do
once you get yourself together
so you can start being crazy with money
and i want you on thanksgiving
you're going to grandma's house to eat
i want you get up a little bit early
and on the way to grandma's house
whether you're going out of town or
crosstown or whatever you're doing load
the kids in the car and budget an extra
30 minutes
and on the way over there i want you to
pull up at waffle house
now some of you poor souls across the
world don't know what waffle house is
you have been withheld from the finer
things in life
but it is a fast
well you call them fast cooking whatever
you do the quick fast it's not it's not
a fast it's not fast food but it's a
chef that cooks quick in front of you
whatever they're a cook because you're
not a chef it's a cook and so they'll
cook it right in front of you on the
griddle right there and it comes really
quick and it's usually greasy
and it's waffles or eggs and it's almost
always greasy and everything's greasy
the orange juice is greasy
it's good
so i i want you to go to waffle house on
thanksgiving morning
i want you to pull up right in front of
the big window they have these big
windows across the front where you can
see inside get the parking spot right in
front
and i want you to leave the kids in the
car
you can leave your spouse in the car you
can even leave it running because it
might be cold
go inside sit at the low bar they got a
little eating bar up there
and i want you to order a cup of coffee
you're not even going to drink the
coffee it's greasy
and i i want you order a cup of coffee
and i i want you to slip three 100 bills
or four one hundred dollar bills on that
cup
walk outside
because you know who's working in waffle
house
somebody needs a job bad
you know he's working in waffle house on
thanksgiving morning
somebody
that life has been tough for lately
it's been tough on her
go out to the car and tell the kids get
off the screens look watch through the
window right here god's getting ready to
show off watch through this window right
here kids everybody watch
here's what she'll do
i've seen her do it
she'll come over and she'll pick it up
and she'll go
now that is kind of funny
until you think about
that her life has been so bad that she
thinks this is a trick
then she'll go
and then even if she's not a person of
faith
she can smell
god's breath
because that's who sent it
when you brought it
and even if she hadn't been in church in
her life or she was there sunday or she
used to go and somebody made her mad or
hurt her feelings doesn't matter what
her story is she still knows the smell
and after she does this she's going to
go
thank you
thank you
and then she'll do a little snoopy dance
right
let your kids watch that happen
all
through their growing up years
and we'll have a nation
that has been changed
you teach your children generosity like
that
you teach them what money's good for and
you teach them how to get some money and
how to stay out of the traps of these
dead gum stinking banks
and you teach them how to live on a
written plan and you say as of my house
as of right now the name ramsey does not
mean broke anymore from this point on
a godly man leaves an inheritance to his
children's children
as it stops
here
i'm going to change my family tree
and if enough of us do that
and we teach our kids outrageous
generosity
we can heal this land
they don't have the answers in the
places where you think they have the
answers and you keep voting waiting on
one of them to grow a brain
you got the answers
you felt it just now didn't you
when we all do this
we can put them out of business
we can make them irrelevant because you
know what will happen with hungry kids
hungry kids will get fed by us
you know what will happen with single
moms 52 percent of them live below the
poverty level will be taking care of
them
you know what happened when somebody
loses their life in the military a
hundred percent of the time the
community will come around and take care
of that family the rest of their life we
won't need va benefits
you know what i'm saying
that's what generosity does but you know
what generosity coming from broke people
is no money
you gotta stop being broke people first
we have to make a decision to
change
hope is what we want you to walk away
from here with
this stuff works i've taught millions
and millions and millions of people how
to get out of debt
how to get on a written plan sow that
they can change their family tree so
that we can be outrageously generous and
change
everything
you can create goals
like george taught you create priorities
like christie taught you and see how
this weaves into being on a budget
getting out of debt so that
we can change our family tree so that we
can be outrageously
generous
it's entirely mathematically possible
but i gotta control this guy in the
mirror
and he's just that guy sometimes
it's okay nobody's gonna be perfect at
it but we're all gonna get better
see we started teaching a class about
gosh 20 years ago 25 years ago now
i used to teach it with an overhead
projector and a bad suit you know
and then we put it on these tapes some
of y'all enough remember vhs tapes we
put it on those and then we put it on
dvds and now we've got this thing called
the internet
and
and so you can get the thing anywhere
now it's called financial peace
university almost 10 million people have
been through the class
that
means that more people have been taught
by this class how to handle money than
any other thing
in existence today
on the planet
okay that's not bragging it's just a
mathematical fact
and we teach people how to get out of
debt how to be married with money how to
be single with money how to invest with
confidence how to handle their insurance
how to buy real estate and not get
ripped off it's the class you should
have been made to take in high school
but nobody knew how to teach it because
the teachers were broke too
but i'm not broke anymore
i've done a lot of dumb things
but the stuff we teach is proven
now you may or may not do it
you may ish
instead of do it completely and issues a
wish you got to do it completely
but if you'll do exactly what we teach
you to do
the stuff i'm talking about will happen
for you
it's happened for me and it's happened
for millions of other people just look
up debt free streams on youtube how many
of them there are it's a bazillion of
them
it's one of the biggest things on
youtube
little oh us
down here in tennessee
with a southern accent which is supposed
to lower your intelligence
the second thing that we know is that
the most important thing you got to do
if you're going to learn to handle money
well is get on a written plan a budget
y'all heard that didn't you say yes
and we built the most powerful most
robust that's what the internet guys
call it uh
budgeting app on the planet the best one
without a doubt not even a close second
in quality in delivery and doing the
stuff that we teach doing the steps that
we teach walking the process is called
every dollar the premium version of
every dollar links to your bank account
so when you use your debit card it
automatically loads into your budget
okay so financial peace university and
every dollar and then put with that a
coach
an online coach that'll be there for you
to answer your questions put with that
that you're in a community you can go to
a class in physical locations if you
want and or you can just take it online
but there's online community and you
know what the online community does they
will bust your chops if you are not
doing it they will love you enough to
say that stupid don't do that
they will kill you
they say stuff like that i'll never i've
never killed anybody but i have a
reputation apparently so
apparently it's a possibility i don't
know but um
but but um i'm kidding but i mean we
want you to win and we want to encourage
you and hold you accountable to the
system that works
so if you hire a personal trainer
and you come in and he has an eight pack
and you have a keg
you should do what he says not your plan
your plan sucks
you should do the other guy's plan it
works
isn't that simple
but we don't do it we all i'm going to
sort of do that but i don't know if i
agree with well you're dumb you're not
doing it why are you why'd you hire him
my wife says if you're not going to do
what the guy says you're just paying him
to count to ten it's kind of expensive
you know
you gotta do the whole thing the
nutrition
and the exercise
you can't exercise enough to eat seven
big macs it just doesn't you can't
outrun a big mac
same thing's true with money right you
submit yourself to this process
and it works
every single time so the premium version
of every dollar the coaching online all
of this is part of now of a ramsay plus
membership
and the easiest way the least most least
expensive way to do that is just do a
year membership on the thing and here's
what we're going to do too tonight we're
going to throw in christy's new book
take back your time okay and you can
either get the audio book if you prefer
or we will ship you the hardback version
whichever one you want you can choose to
select when you go to the the gameplan
bundle dot com and select everything
that's going on so here's the deal all
of that together is 149 normal pricing
and we're gonna put the lowest price on
it we put this year because america
needs a game plan
it's time for us to change
and we're gonna do the whole thing for
99 bucks right now
and you spent that on pizza
i don't need the money
but i also know that if i gave it to you
for free you probably wouldn't do it
pay just a little bit you're like i got
to do this stuff i paid money for it
so i'm gonna hold you accountable
and uh that gives me the money to pay
that single mom that works here too by
the way
so this is how this whole thing works
it's a trade out
and uh we're very happy with that trade
gameplanbundle.com that's where you go
and it's
the best deal that we've done in the
last 14 months
so 99 bucks and it includes christy's
book which is the number one bestseller
again we just got that word today and
we're very very proud of her on that
so it works out this way
i got obsessed with ancestry.com because
i want to look up all of my the noble
hillbilly heritage of the ramses
and it is a noble heritage i mean we've
got all kinds of characters in there a
bunch of preachers in there and i just
would love to go back and meet some of
those guys
you know
you know musket carrying people coming
across the north carolina border into
what became tennessee later you know who
are these men who are these women that
you know that lived on hunted bear and i
mean i just it's amazing me and one of
my my grandmother's grandfather was a
circuit writing preacher he was in the
union army he was he was a yankee and um
methodist boy and he decided after the
war to come south and preach to the
southerners so he came south as a
circuit riding preacher and i've got his
bible from 1876.
pretty cool and
i've got a lot of stories about him he's
a wonderful character of a man i mean
that's pretty brave be yankee come south
and preach
there's a lot of stuff that people
didn't like right then okay and so you
you are meddling at no end there i would
love to hear the stuff he went through
but i'll hear it in heaven
and so i was talking to my cousin i said
i've been looking at all these people
i'm building out the family tree and
everything he goes yeah i got a bunch of
we started comparing notes and he said
you know they're buried right over there
in maryvale by your grandpa and i said
really and he told me where the stone
was and everything so next time i was
down there in east tennessee we wrote
rode down to the thing and i went back
there to find because i thought i'm just
enamored with the thing i wanted to find
his gravestone so i found his gravestone
and sure enough there was
the date he was born
and the day he died
and that's true on every one of men
there
and there's that thing in the middle
the dash
and that's where it all happened
that's where the action took place
so my challenge for you
is what are you going to do with your
dash
you got one shot at it
what are you gonna do
change
i've had it i'm not living like this
anymore i'm gonna change this
so
three generations from now some little
character is wandering through a
graveyard looking for my gravestone
because i left a mark on history
what are you going to do
with your family tree
and you leave a mark on it
what are you gonna do with your dash
it's an honor to be with you all tonight
i love you god bless you
thank you
[Music]
you